ten weeks as we've mentioned ten weeks
from tonight
is when thursday night in tampa kicks
off a 2021 season
and the buccaneers raise a banner with
the dallas cowboys in their house
tampa bay times buccaneers reporter rick
stroud here on the rich eisen show how
are you rick
i'm doing well rich when you say 10
weeks man that sounds like
it's 10 days to me so um
going to be exciting for sure well i
know and that's why i figured you know
what i know we're a couple weeks away
from
training camp and a couple weeks removed
from from
um mini camp and things like that and
everyone's on vacation including you and
i appreciate you taking the time to
to call into the show and what is the
state of the franchise
uh of the team that uh has a great
chance to be the first repeat since
brady's
patriots team of the arts rick
you know it's kind of surreal i mean
they're they're euphoric obviously
um what happened last year i'm not sure
anyone has completely processed
you know they're going to get their
rings coming up here i think on the 22nd
of july i think that's
where you put a bow on on last season
but with all that transpired from
from brady you know choosing the
buccaneers
um the pandemic the lack of training
camp all of that the seven and five
start
you know to pull off what they did uh
with a 43 year old quarterback as great
as he is is really remarkable and uh
you know to get all 22 starters
back and resigned um and brady to be
more familiar with the offense and and
his players
i think they have a great chance uh of
repeating we know how ridiculous that
sounds how hard that is to do he's the
last one to do it
you know 304 with the patriots so um
yeah that there's not a seat in the
house rich you can't buy
a regular you know game day ticket you
have to be a season pass member that's
and they have a waiting list that's how
good it is is that right
i mean that is incredible rick because
if we just
you know uh snapped right back
just flash frame right back to this
point last year
what you everything you just said would
have been the ultimate dream scenario
for the bucks in signing tom brady
everything that you said
from the fact of winning it all and
there's now a wait for season tickets
and they wouldn't lose anybody from
winning at all
in terms of their starters or coaching
staff right nobody
they didn't get poached at all correct
that's the biggest thing rich you know
you talk about
uh having that many players back and
those guys are all
really good players some of them are
older though let's not be naive you know
when you have an indomicon zoo and a
jason pierre paul
uh generally you know players don't get
more productive
and less hurt as they get older in this
league so you know every year is
different there's no doubt about that
but the biggest return
are the two coordinators i mean you know
start with todd bowles
in the job that he did with that young
defense you know they got experience up
front obviously with shaq barrett and
jason pierre-paul
and domiconsu but then you look at the
young linebackers chris levante david's
a veteran he's back but devin white that
secondary is all young
and the job that they did and how they
improved a guy like vida veya able to
come
back in the playoffs i think made all
the difference and so now year three
with todd bowles who
who got two or three interviews but
wasn't hired
same thing could be said about byron
leftwich who i think he's going to be a
rising star in this league look tom
brady
has made a lot of head coaches of his
coordinators this may be the next one
but
that continuity on that coaching staff
is what allows bruce harrion's you know
to
to be sort of the ceo coach that he is
and i just think that all of that is so
very important
ten weeks from tonight again the
buccaneers hosting the cowboys to kick
off the 2021 season in tampa and tampa
bay times reporter rick stroud here on
the rich eisen show
um so let's just uh play a hypothetical
here we're all drinking with aryans
right now okay we're we're a few we're a
few uh
fingers into the drink right
um and we ask him your biggest concern
for the season is what what does he say
do you think when i lose wee boos baby
uh uh he's gonna say injuries
you know i think that's the thing that
that most coaches fear you know the nfl
is a war of attrition and we saw with
the kansas city chiefs as great as
patrick mahomes
is and he was terrific uh even in that
game they chased them some 500 yards
if you get some injuries in some bad
places like like offensive tackle
like the chiefs uh you know did uh it
can wreck your season
and you know i i think bruce has been
smart he's got a veteran team
um if you watch him rich during the week
you know these guys
that are up there in the in age even
including brady who was struggling with
that knee injury that we know about
um you know he gives them days off and
you know late in the season especially
with the 17th game this year
they may not practice at all until maybe
friday or or even then depending on what
they're dealing with so
i think bruce does as good a job as any
coach
trying to to manage the workload you
know during the week and
and we saw that in the off season they
cut down the otas
to about 10 days it was mostly
backups and rookies um brady did his
thing on the side he came in for the
mandatory mini camp and
what was remarkable rich was watching
these guys they had been working on the
side
and i know this is easy to say but they
were so precise
and and maybe the season was so long
they didn't have that much time off but
i think they could have beaten half the
teams on their schedule when they came
back in
for the three-day mini camp so look i
mean
the optimism is high but uh but i would
say you know going back to your original
question i think injuries i think if you
stay healthy
you got a lot of older players that's
the only thing they would fear
and you know rick the relationship with
brady and aryans it's amazing um
and brady in the organization it is
amazing it is exactly what they wanted
it's exact the first year is exactly
what they wanted and being positioned
for year two is exactly what they wanted
and you know long gone or the
you know was it really brady's fault or
was it mike evans fault and that week
one
interception that wasn't the pick six
right i mean like it's
those are long gone and they may never
come back
and they shouldn't but the question is
right now
um that's my long-winded setup for
having aryans and
jason light on the show rick and i've
asked them both about their relationship
with brady
and they both were talking openly about
texting him at me
light was like hey i texted him about
what about geo bernard
and and and uh aaron's is like i texted
him
what about what you know what guys you
thinking about in the draft right
and i'm wondering if those guys are you
know they answer the question
if they're proud to say this sort of
stuff because they know what messes with
everybody else's quarterback
franchise relationship in the nfl what
do you what do you think rick
well we've seen that dynamic obviously
with aaron rodgers and i i
yeah you know the the quarterback uh
our stars in this league they're
realizing their power now tom was a free
agent so he could choose his situation
and obviously
there really isn't anything i think they
would say no to tom brady about
um you know but the relationship still
still had to be bonded i mean he
he knew about bruce syrians i think he
knew what to expect and talking to
peyton manning and other guys he had
coached
but look when he called him out in week
one uh i know tom eventually said all
the right things about
you know well i want to be coach start
he's the coach and you know so what
i think it stung him a little bit and i
don't think that's the way he wanted to
start the relationship and
you know there were a lot of things with
that offense that tom needed that he
didn't have
to start the year and we saw that evolve
and i think that's a credit
to that relationship which took some
time to build you know
byron leftwich was doing the offense
pretty much by himself uh
in in conjunction with brady bruce was
it's his offense but he was hands off in
terms of game planning
it took them about 11 to 12 weeks to
figure out hey we need to more
commitment to running the ball
we need some play action you know we
need these things for tom
because you can't just drop back and you
know you know throw it down the field
every play which is what bruce wants to
do with the 43 year old quarterback so
it's been a work in progress i think tom
has changed
everything in organization i've seen it
from afar but not seen it up close
rich never known a player that i've
covered anyway
that everybody in the organization wants
to please i mean to the point where
you know it's a cliche you know the cook
has to cook better and they have to
clean the the meeting rooms better and
all of that
but these guys don't want to disappoint
tom brady and and they know he
he's been to the to the dance more than
anybody else
he's won the most super bowls and it's
really changed the culture of the
franchise i think as much as anything
that's that's what the bucks were after
they'll take the lombardi trophies don't
get me wrong
but you know he brought a a work ethic
and a precision
to this franchise that they had been
lacking in in a culture that
bruce arians was trying to you know
trying to instill but
you know winning is culture right it's a
chicken and the egg thing but this guy
has won more than any quarterback and
that's what he has now with the bucks
you know it's crazy rick stroud of tampa
bay times here and the rich eisen show
covers the bucks
uh world champion it's crazy you know
what you just said and
many people might be seeing it hearing
it and saying
of course they're going to roll out the
red carpet for tom brady and do whatever
the heck he wants and there's nothing
that they'll say no to and things like
that but
that's an uh it's such an outlier in the
nfl that it has messed with other
quarterbacks heads
you know so so that's why i'm saying
like maybe light and airings don't mind
kind of puffing their chests out a
little bit and saying yeah sometimes a
simple way is the right way
and and it's still my team as a coach
and it still lights front office
like they've they've hit the mother lode
the bucks in a way that other franchises
won't attempt or their freight attempt
to refuse to attempt depending on
the philosophies as we're seeing in
green bay in a way it's kind of crazy
rick you know and there's there's not
many uh you know
quarterbacks you would do that for right
no um aaron rodgers would be one you
would think
but again you know jason is you know he
i think he gets a little shaped when
people say well
you know tom is the gm and and he's not
obviously
and and i suppose there might be a
player that he's asked
about and they've said no to i don't
know i don't know the one that that
would include at this point but
um in as much as you know yeah i i think
that it is
changing the culture of of the position
and i think you're going to see
more movement um you know look uh
matthew stafford goes to the rams i
think that might be the biggest
acquisition
of the offseason right that might that
might change the entire
nfc who knows but
matching these players with these
situations at that position
can put you over the top there's no more
more important position in the game so
if you have one um you might want to
listen to them especially one that
you know has played as long as guys like
rogers and uh
and brady like i said there's not too
many of them you would do that for
but certainly they were willing to do it
here and um
you know i think brady also look he he
benefited
from a change of scenery you know he he
got all he squeezed all he could out of
the patriots and bill belichick and we
can debate forever who was more
responsible it really doesn't matter at
the end of the day those guys won more
than anywhere
and but but it's refreshing for him i
mean tom
you know we saw vodka katila tequila tom
you know at the boat parade we saw
him on social media all the time he's
you know enjoys the warm weather which
is good for his 43 year old body
there's so much he gained and bruce
arians who couldn't be
you know more than 180 degrees away from
his approach than bill belichick was
so all of those things i think factored
into brady being at his best as well
rick stroud couple more minutes left
with uh the tampa bay times reporter
that's been covering the bucks for
for a long time here on the rich eisen
show on the day at 10 weeks until the
kickoff to the
nfl season 2021 you just mentioned that
we've seen
vodka vodka tequila tom we've also
seen carpool karaoke tom we've seen
trash talking uh golfing tom and then
we just saw a dishing tom on the shop
on hbo with lebron and also
maverick carter and chelsea handler and
draymond green etc
and so um you i'm sure have had
conversations
whatever you might be willing to share
about tom's
free agency tour that wound up
him choosing uh tampa do you have
any educated guess on which team he was
referring to and which quarterback was
the mfr that he referred to
on the shop rick do you have any guests
there
well i mean look i think every team that
that uh
had an interest in him have all assumed
that it's them right so that's
that's mission accomplished by brady um
you know i love that really probably
what he was after in the first place i
mean the thing about tom and he said it
he said it in the barber shop or
whatever is that 90
of what he says is complete bs what he
said you know what i thought it was 95
it turns out it's only 90. speaking of
somebody's been on the business end of
all of that whether it's 90 or 95
somebody yeah exactly so uh but
but look i mean you know
yeah he he looked at all these teams and
it look if i had to guess
yes please i mean if you're just asking
my educated guests yeah
um the teams that i think he really
considered
i think sanford i think the 49ers were
the ones that were in the
toughest position i don't know who the
hell tom was thought like i said he
probably wanted all of them to believe
it
but the 49ers were in a situation with
garoppolo from a contractual standpoint
i think they would have loved to have
happened
and there wasn't a team think about tom
brady grew up in the bay area right
yep um his heroes were montana and young
he was a chance to go to a team that he
knew was
going to be very good um to his hometown
team
and they were stuck i mean they were
stuck with garoppolo
uh they couldn't get out from under that
contract and even if they wanted to they
couldn't trade them
so that's that's kind of i think you
know
just just looking at the tea leaves here
i mean where would he want to go more
than tampa bay i know i've heard you
know well new orleans was it yeah
uh i i don't i don't buy that
i think the chargers were in it i know
the bucks were definitely in it because
he signed there
um there was a time when i'm sure he did
talk to sean payton or his allies did
whatever
um but at the end of the day i think the
49ers were probably
the one that was that was stuck you know
that
might have pulled the trigger on it but
just simply couldn't get out and i mean
you know where did jimmy garoppolo come
from right
a guy that tom knew very very well but
again haven't talked to him about it
my guess is he wants all those guys to
think that they they screwed him
i love that by the way i think rick i
think that i think you're
spot on right there but i do think there
is an actual team
um the one i guess and then i'll let you
go the one that i guess
is the titans because i remember you
know
uh the vrabel facetime of of of edelman
and brady just before the pandemic when
they're at a syracuse college basketball
game in the carrier dome
that the titans i remember the titans
were interested i remember that being
a very found well founded rumor
and they they had a decision to make on
taneo right at the same time
i said they had to make that decision on
tannehill and i think they
they said to tom you know we're going to
stick with our guy and
that that may be the the guy in question
you know that's that's my guess rick at
least
yeah and it's as good as mine or anyone
else's
only tom knows and i assure you he'll be
the only one that will know
i know i got to let you go rick but i do
want to give you a couple minutes before
we go you tweeted about it today monty
kiffin's going into the
ring of honor this fall in tampa what
what are your recollections of the the
dc
uh of all those terrific buccaneer teams
that have sent so many people to the pro
football hall of fame
well i think you start there right um
you know tony dungy
look it was a great defensive mind of
his own but he turned that thing over to
monty early on
and they took a franchise that had not
won
for decades and and turned it around and
made it a perennial playoff contender
went to a championship game
eventually monty was on with john gruden
when they won the super bowl
um just a character of the game in
addition to being
a great defensive coordinator when you
can handle personalities like warren
sapp derek brooks and john lynch
uh as varied as those guys are um and
simeon rice thrown in there
you're doing something well and you know
monty
i i i'm great glad to see it because i
think a lot of times assistant coaches
get overlooked
by their contributions there's not too
many on hall on ring of honors
so um just happy for him and all his
players will be there he's beloved
and um you know i just i'm just glad
that he gets his his day in the sun
because
uh he certainly deserves it and also
that means lane gets to be back in the
nfl for at least one day so that
that's great for all of us that's great
for all of us yeah cue the lane
cue the lane kit from the coaching
rumors when he shows up
you take care of yourself rick enjoy
your time uh off time down with family
and friends and let's chat when uh when
training camps open i look forward to it
great to be with you rich
let's do it again right back at you rick
stroud at nfl stroud
on twitter i follow him you should as
well this man is on top of
everything with the defending world
champs hey you watched all the way to
the end
thanks for that watch more right here